personne secourus se trouve dans une
situation d'urgence absolue des
prévisions météo indiquent une
détérioration significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel
est le député qui vient de prononcer
cette phrase
alors il a eu la plus grosse sanction
qu'est-ce qui s'est dit vendredi
après-midi donc le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale a décidé à l'unanimité une
censure avec exclusion temporaire au
député du arène donc il pourra pas venir
à l'Assemblée pendant 15 jours il va
perdre la moitié de son indemnité
pendant deux mois c'est la plus lourde
sanction vous y attendiez ou pas vous
êtes dit ça oui parce que les personnes
qui sont chargées de prononcer la
sanction sont les personnes qui sont à
l'opposé du rassemblement social donc
c'est en marche c'est les députés de la
nupesse c'est les députés de gauche donc
on n'est pas surpris de la tension
exactement oui bon on n'est pas surpris
donc on s'attendait une sanction mais si
vous voulez ce qui est bon d'abord la
remarque de mon collègue n'était pas
d'une finesse extraordinaire on l'a dit
en tout cas juste on a cherché à faire
croire et c'est là où moi je vois ça un
peu comme une injustice qu'il parlait du
député en question alors qu'on est en
train de parler de d'un bateau d'un
bateau d'une ONG qui va chercher des
migrants généralement des bateaux de
migrants qui sont présents aux abords
des ports africains qu'on va ramener sur
le sol européen c'est à dire en France
ou en Italie et
dans un débat parlementaire où ça fuse
dans tous les sens parce que si l'on
isole en fait 5 secondes mais à
l'Assemblée nationale il faut bien se
rendre compte c'est un peu pareil au
Parlement ça fuse mais cette année c'est
plus ce bordel que les hôtels ça fuse
peut-être mais ça fuse dans tous les
sens et donc là en parlant du bateau il
dit qu'il retourne et on a cherché à
dans une tentative vraiment je trouve
malhonnête et en réalité d'intimidation
parce qu'on a cherché à nous intimider
pour nous empêcher de parler de la
politique d'immigration moi si vous
voulez ce que je conseille ce que je
contaise c'est que on cherche à nous à
nous empêcher de parler du fond et le
fond c'est la politique migratoire on
est on est d'accord qu'il aurait jamais
dû dire ça comme ça mais je suis le
premier à le dire et moi je fais je fais
toujours attention de de bien choisir
mes mots parce que un mot mal compris
mal dit etc
c'est incontestable sur les réseaux je
suis allé sur son compte là
s'il vous plaît Valérie Benaim on est ça
c'est ça c'est un mec qui vous fait du
mal dans le pertinent je vais vous dire
il y a des tweets qui sont prenons des
trucs qui sont sortis mais si vous
voulez quand vous investissez moi
j'étais président de la commission
d'investiture on a investi 577 candidats
il y a des gens qu'on connaît il y a des
gens qu'on connaît moins il y a des gens
qui sont avec nous depuis très longtemps
si vous voulez c'est vrai qu'on ne peut
pas aller regarder ce que chacun Twitter
il y a 10 ans non mais donc c'est vrai
que parfois ben comme vous on découvre
aussi et on sonne pas les cœurs
découvrent des trucs que nous on
n'aurait pas fait que moi je n'aurais
pas fait mal le président du parti
est-ce que vous allez le convoquer ou
est-ce que vous allez lui parler mais je
lui ai parlé quoi je lui dis que c'était
pas très fin quoi alors ouais mais je
lui dis que sur le fond si vous voulez
moi je j'accepte pas qu'on explique
qu'il a eu des propos racistes qui
visait le député en question parce que
le député serait de couleur noire je
n'accepte pas cela parce que ce genre de
réflexion et de comportement on a
toujours été intraitable avec cela en
tout cas Marine Le Pen depuis qu'elle
est présent du mouvement a toujours été
intrêtable quand il y a des trucs à
sanctionner on les sanctionne mais quand
le propos est incompris et qui a une
Kabbale qui s'organise sur un député de
la République bah ouais je trouve pas ça
je trouve pas d'accord et d'ailleurs
vous parlez de la sanction du bureau de
l'Assemblée le bureau de l'Assemblée a
liberté l'accusation de racisme et en
fait il est sanctionné et ça donc sur la
base de l'article
mais pour avoir créé un tumulte dans
l'assemblée hallucinant donc ils ont ils
ont dit quoi sur l'enquête ils ont dit
qu'il ne s'adressaient pas députés bah
il est avéré dans le procès verbal on
reconnaît qu'il parlait du bateau en
question donc voilà le propos est pas
faim mais est-ce que ça justifie une
cabale en allant expliquer que c'est de
la xénophobie du racisme etc je crois
pas et je crois pas pourquoi parce que
je pense qu'il y a une majorité de
Français dans notre pays qui ne souhaite
pas que on accueille une immigration
supplémentaire et qui pense que les
bateaux doivent être secourus et
raccompagner dans les portes de départ
c'est tout ce qu'on a dit sur le pense
chacun pense il veut juste là comme vous
l'avez dit il a fait une connerie on va
se mentir il a déconné il lui avait dit
ça ça c'est c'est ce genre de de sortie
c'est vrai que c'est c'est pas bon pour
vous
je pense qu'il s'est aperçu de sa
maladresse dans la fin parce que ça a pu
créer une incompréhension alors je pense
que la place qu'on occupe aujourd'hui
est une place de potentiel
présidentielle ça n'a pas parti qui peut
potentiellement dans 5 ans être à la
tête de l'État et donc je pense qu'il
faut faire très attention auxquels vous
présenter le mot qu'on utilise moi je
souhaite que ce soit Marine Le Pen mais
elle souhaite que ce soit vous non elle
a dit qu'elle n'a pas pris sa décision
encore et qu'elle adorait mais non non
pas du tout je vais vous dire moi je
suis je suis honnête que ma voix je
pense Jordan
je pense qu'elle a il y a 10 ans elle
faisait 17% à la présidentielle
aujourd'hui elle a fait 42 on a le
premier groupe de position à l'Assemblée
et je pense que quand on a comme elle
une notoriété une popularité dont on a
pu se rendre compte d'ailleurs reçu tu
as une notoriété
oui mais j'ai le temps et je pense
qu'elle en a beaucoup plus à 27 ans
72 enfin 2050 il paraît qu'il va avoir
le réchauffement climatique tu pourras
pas venir en coller
non mais je te le dis je te dis genre
maintenant mais juste est-ce que je
question parce que c'est est-ce que si
ça avait été un autre député parce que
lui c'est la première fois qu'il prenait
la parole l'assemblé on parle de cette
histoire c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
aussi est-ce que il aurait fait la même
chose le député du RN c'est vrai que lui
c'est la première fois qu'il prenait la
parole il a 31 ans c'est voilà c'est un
député de la France insoumise on sait
que la France insoumise c'est pas c'est
pas votre tasse de thé est-ce qu'il
aurait fait la même chose avec un député
voilà connu euh voilà de la République
en marche est-ce qu'il aurait fait
l'amour
il y a beaucoup de nouveaux non mais
c'est juste vous êtes dans un débat
parlementaire là les députés faut se
rendre compte depuis le mois de juin il
siège jour et nuit qui sont à 9h du
matin en séance en commission ils vont
jusqu'à des séances qui va jusqu'à 2h du
matin 3h il y a descends jusqu'à 5h du
matin pour le vote du texte sur de
pouvoir d'achat donc si oui dans des
débats où vous êtes enfermé pendant des
heures et des heures ça fuse dans tous
les sens bon voilà maintenant je veux
pas que ça écrit le sujet de fond et le
sujet de Fond aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y
a une majorité de Français qui considère
qu'il faut maîtriser l'immigration en
France ce qui n'est pas fait par le
gouvernement on me dit qu'il y a pas de
pas avoir d'accusation de racisme c'est
pas dans le règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est ça Gilles oui absolument
c'est vrai c'est ça que la sonde oui
c'est la sanction maximale quand même
bordel là et moi j'ai l'impression que
là vous tentez vous expliquer avec brio
comme d'habitude mais vous tentez de
minimiser et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
y a un autre député de chez vous
monsieur cabrolier qui a fait un tweet
pour à propos de l'affaire et de
Monsieur Milongo je voulais le tweet
pour monter à l'arbre de l'antirascisme
il faut avoir les fesses propres ça
commence à buzzer c'est déjà pris par
beaucoup de gens comme sous-entendu
monsieur bilongo et noir est-ce que
c'est pas le singe qui monte au cocotier
en fait non mais non mais monsieur
Bardella à chaque fois il est là
derrière vous le twei à chaque fois avec
le gars était derrière moi
à chaque fois Monsieur bordel on il
accuse de quoi
carlosez excusez-moi parce que j'ai pas
vu le truc dans la cuisine
parce que Monsieur
député RN pour que tout le monde
comprenne qu'est-ce que j'ai pas j'ai
pas vu le truc monsieur bilongo commence
à avoir autour de lui certaines
polémiques sur ses comportements sur
quoi alors des liens avec les islamistes
dans les finales avec un imam qui n'est
pas un nouveau député qui est un un
visage propre et cetera c'est-à-dire que
il a déjà des casseroles de copinage
avec les islamistes dans les cités etc
donc c'est pas après ça on va voir ce
que j'étais en train d'expliquer ça il y
a des il a des casseries il aurait des
casseroles autour de lui qui monte
d'accord participation à une
manifestation à Sarcelles en 2014 la
dégénéré en émeute antisémite donc il
est possible voilà tout ça sera
peut-être actuellement
trois choses donc participation enfin
lien avec c'est avéré ça ou c'est des
bruits
il y a une vidéo avec un imam de
Villiers-le-Bel qui a été sanctionné
très durement pour apologie du
terrorisme voilà avec Monsieur bilongo
il s'est en photo il y aurait des liens
avec une association turque qui prône en
islam politique soutenu par le président
de la Turquie ça je ne nie pas monsieur
pour monter à l'arbre de l'antiracisme
il faut avoir les fesses propres est-ce
que ça c'est digne d'un débat
parlementaire monsieur Bardella parce
que là très clairement ça veut dire
excusez-moi vous êtes noir monté
excusez-moi
mais le problème c'est que je pense que
vous arrivez pas à vous à vous départir
d'une d'une caricature que vous avez du
rassemblement national
je veux juste
vous rappeler que nous on reconnaît que
les Français sans aucune distinction de
race d'origine ou de religion et
peut-être la meilleure preuve de cela
c'est que au premier des élections
présidentielles comme aux dernières
élections européennes où j'étais le
candidat du RN on est arrivé en tête en
outre-mer donc si vous voulez cette
accusation de de subliminal racine parce
qu'en fait il y a pas grand chose il y a
même rien de répréhensible par la loi en
fait vous l'avez en vous mais je l'avais
dit mais je pense que cette image ne
correspond pas à la réalité et je pense
qu'elle est fausse et elle est
extrêmement diffamante quand on sait
aussi l'origine de gens qui dans notre
parent des origines
mais le focus que vous faites chez nous
vous ne le faites que chez nous
nazi dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a trois mois il n'écope
pas de la peine maximale quand vous avez
un député en marche donc j'ai pu le nom
qui a fracassé il y a 3-4 ans un casque
sur le crâne d'un député PS il n'a pas
pris cette sanction donc si vous voulez
et je vais même vous dire mercredi il y
a un de nos députés un député de Moselle
qui s'appelle Alexandre Loubet qui a
traité vous en avez peut-être parlé le
ministre de l'économie de lâche il y a
quelques jours là parce que nous nous
considérons que Emmanuel Macron et Bruno
Le Maire ont bradé les intérêts français
quand ils ont vendu notre industrie
nucléaire nos entreprises stratégiques
comme alsom aux Américains de générateur
électrique on le dit vous êtes des
lâches et pour cela Alexandre Loubet va
être sanctionné et mercredi la prison de
l'Assemblée nationale a demandé à ce que
soit supprimé une partie de son
indemnité donc moi je pense que la
liberté d'expression est aujourd'hui en
danger la liberté sur le truc qu'on
vient de lire c'est la liberté
on peut pas laisser passer
mais je ne sais même pas dans quel
contexte j'ai dit je suis désolé pour
vous donner plus de détails mais si
c'est pas faim je vous le dirai mais
juste nous faites pas d'accusation
gratuite et subliminale quand en fait il
y a plus grand chose à me reprocher
aujourd'hui voilà après pour ce qui
relève du reste j'ai le débat
parlementaire c'est le débat
parlementaire la démocratie française la
l'idée même de démocratie c'est de
pouvoir tout dire à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le respect évidemment
mais de quoi avoir des mots de pouvoir
non non non bien sûr mais de pouvoir
avoir des mots qui parfois sont durs qui
parfois sont abrutis peut-être parfois
peuvent paraître violents mais je veux
dire s'il y a plus ça dans la démocratie
à l'Assemblée nationale où je rappelle
les députés que ce soit français ou
européens sont protégés par une immunité
parlementaire pour ce qu'ils disent
alors il y a plus de démocratie et je
veux dire la violence des mots en
démocratie ça remplace la violence
physique dans la rue Jordan Bardella
pour vous la sanction elle est lourde ou
bien elle est normale
mais la sanction je la trouve
injustifiée je la trouve injustifiée
parce que ce sont des propos qui ne
relèvent pas de la loi vous avez dit que
c'est je veux dire mais c'est maladroit
mais je veux dire l'Assemblée nationale
je veux dire c'est le temple de la
liberté d'expression quand il dit qu'il
retourne en Afrique en parlant d'un
bateau en parlant d'un retour du bateau
dans son port de départ c'est pas fin je
vous l'accorde ça donne peut-être pas la
meilleure image du rassemble je vous
l'accorde et je ne l'aurais pas dit et
Marine Le Pen non plus mais mais juste
sur le fond ça c'est une opinion
politique on a le droit de dire on
souhaite que ce bateau soit raccompagné
dans son port de départ en l'occurrence
le bateau concernant un bateau en
interpellant le voilà c'est c'est mais
pourquoi pas en interpellant inverser ça
l'Assemblée nationale ici donc tout le
monde s'interpelle donc après on n'est
pas là
il y en a pas un qui mais encore pire
parce qu'à l'Assemblée à ça on devrait
avoir une liberté d'expression qui est
encore plus sacralisée et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les députés ont une
immunité parlementaire qui fait que un
député dans l'hémicycle a le droit de
tout dire et n'a pas le droit d'être C
dans la Constitution d'être poursuivi
pour des propos ou des opinions
politiques donc je veux dire attention
parce qu'on est sur une frontière il y
avait pas une structure comme ça depuis
2011 je crois qu'il y en a même pas je
crois qu'il y en a que ici je crois
qu'il y en a eu que deux dans l'histoire
de la 5e mais on paye aussi si vous
voulez le faire d'avoir je pense une
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale qui
est comme tous les autres personnes en
marche et une techno c'est-à-dire qu'on
a eu dans l'histoire de la vie politique
française des des vrais politiques qui
étaient des gens de l'opposition Claude
Bartolone qui était au PS Monsieur
Seguin monsieur Ferrand des gens qui
avaient une épaisseur politique et qui
était comme président de l'Assemblée les
garants des droits de l'opposition or
moi j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui
qu'avec Emmanuel Macron la liberté
d'expression régresse dans notre pays
parce que si les députés ne peuvent plus
avoir encore une fois une liberté
d'expression saine et apaisée alors
c'est fini la démocratie française
liberté d'expression incroyable ici par
exemple voilà ici on l'a voilà Mathieu
tu voulais dire un truc non mais score
du mal à comprendre c'est le paradoxe
entre entre le fait qu'il y ait sanction
mais qui ne reconnaissent pas le le
racisme de la phrase soit il la
reconnaisse et il y a sanction et je
suis d'accord au passé un autre débat
soit il la reconnaisse pas
en fait il est sanctionné c'est le 70-1
du réglement intérieur pour avoir créé
un tumulte une scène de tumulte dans
l'Assemblée nationale en fait mais donc
normalement ce n'était pas intentionnel
et qui crée le tumuls c'est les députés
LFI exetera qui font du cinéma en
expliquant qu'on a visé ce député en
fonction de sa couleur de peau comme ça
il a interpellé voilà c'est toute la
journée nationale c'est de tous les
bords l'hémicycle il y a beaucoup de
tumuls vous croyez que quand nous on
veut on se fait traiter de fachos ça
nous fait plaisir et on
se victimise non bon voilà et là il y a
pas qu'un parti le reste de l'hémistique
qui s'est levé
parce que ce sont nos opposants
politiques c'est normal la sanction est
prononcée en fait par la France
insoumise et nuque et et en marche donc
c'est normal que si oui ils prennent la
sanction la plus difficile quoi